This edition of Scoutmasters podcast brought to you by the folks of Conahoe Creek Outfitters.
They know camping and they know scouts. They are scouts
And they know how to get you great gear and great prices for all your camping adventures.
So go visit them at conahoecreakcom, at conohocreakcom.
And now the old scout master.
We noted recently on the blog that the Meribatch Blue Card went under a slight revision dealing with the unit leader's signature
Right. You remember that I have some inside information that may be of interest to you.
That's right That the Meribatch Blue Card soon will be printed on material that will actually be able to go through the laundry and survive.
How about that?
This is podcast number 156..
Hey, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag and see who we've heard from this week.
Kelly is in Arkansas and she wrote in to say
I'm actually a volunteer and staff member of the Girl Scouts in Arkansas.
I absolutely love your 15 thoughts for scout leaders infographic.
I'd like permission to adapt it a bit so that it's Girl Scout related and share it with our members.
This is really an amazing site. It's full of useful information for all scouts.
Can I put a link to your website on our site.
Thanks so much for your time. And, Kelly, thank you so much for being in touch.
I'm glad you're finding things useful.
Everything on scoutmastercgcom is there to be useful,
So do put a link to your site. That's absolutely fine
If you would like to repost any of the materials that you find there.
share the Scoutmaster podcast. whatever you like to do,
The only caveat is just that it's attributed to scoutmastercgcom, That's all.
But please, folks, feel free to use any of the material.
You don't have to write and ask permission.
Like I said, all we look for is that it's attributed to scoutmastercgcom.
Thanks for being in touch again. Kelly Certainly appreciate hearing from you.
Greg Combs is in troop 10 in Cornelius, North Carolina,
And he wrote in to say thanks for all you do.
Ron Herrera is in Harbor Creek, Erie, Pennsylvania, troop 97..
I'm the scoutmaster of a troop that went from four to over 20 in one year
And we have been working hard to develop a great program for the scouts.
The problem was is that we were creating the program.
I now have an adult leadership group that's dedicated to turning control of the troop
over to the scouts, where it belongs.
We have completed the intro to leader training with our patrol leaders council
and followed up with additional sessions to debrief past performances
and where they're going next.
What I'm finding the hardest part is actually letting go.
I enjoy doing some of the planning, but I also know that it must move over to the scouts.
I'm listening to the podcast and reading the blog.
I've just downloaded the series on youth leadership and look forward
to getting a couple of good pointers out of that.
Thanks for the blog and for the podcast.
They're a great source of not only information but inspiration.
Thanks so much, Ron.
Thanks for being in touch and I'm glad you're finding things useful.
Ron, you know you're not alone.
I mean, everybody finds it challenging in one way or another
to get the whole youth leadership thing down.
It's unusual,
It's unique to scouting,
It's something that we've never worked with before, most of us-
and it takes some time.
But my congratulations to you on committing to it and making it happen.
You will never regret it and your scouts will thank you for it.
Hey, back to our friend Bill Fleming at Conahoe Creek.
How you doing, Bill?
Doing great. Clark, How are you doing?
We're doing great.
You know we've been talking about the scout bundle that you've put together,
which is a great selection of carefully chosen basic camping gear
for a new scout or even a scout that's been around for a while.
And one of the choices that you made in there is a headlamp,
And I think that's pretty much what everybody uses now.
I remember the old days of the flashlight
and I'm real happy to have a headlamp.
Tell me a little bit about the headlamp you chose.
Well, I'll tell you, headlamps in general
I think are one of the best inventions for guys that are camping.
I remember as a scout washing dishes in the dark
holding a flashlight in my mouth so I could see what I was trying to do.
You know, then you drop your light
and then you kick the light trying to pick it up
And you know it's just a misery.
But the headlamp will help prevent part of that
And this headlamp gives a good illumination, good run time.
It uses AAA batteries, so it's not a strange battery
that you can pick those up anywhere.
And one of the things that amazes me about the LED technology
in headlamps is how long they last.
It seemed like the batteries in the old-style flashlights ran out all the time.
These LED lights- they don't use much electricity,
so they keep going and going.
Oh yeah, they do very well.
We have several other lamps there again.
If you want to switch out to something that's brighter or different,
contact us and we'll help. you know, customize that bundle for you.
This product is one of the Bear Grylls products from Gerber.
It's part of this gear bundle that's customizable to fit your needs,
fit exactly what you want,
And you go to connehocreekcom-
c-o-n-o-h-o-creekcom for this
and you'll get in touch with Bill Fleming and he'll set you up
with the kind of gear that you need at a really great price.
If you have any questions, don't hesitate to contact us
and you know that's what we're all about at Conneho Creek.
One more time: connehocreekcom, c-o-n-o-h-o-creek.
When you do your shopping there, use the special coupon code
for the Scout Master Podcast.
Get an extra 5% off with coupon code CG113..
CG113..
Our next Scout Circle, which is a live presentation and broadcast,
will be coming up on February 10th
and our guest is going to be David Scott,
who is the author of the book The Scouting Part.
February is our anniversary month.
We thought it'd be interesting to have a little bit of scouting history in February.
If you haven't got David's book The Scouting Party,
there'll be a link to how to get that book in the post that contains this podcast.
It's really a fascinating story about Baden Powell, Ernest Thompson Seaton,
Daniel Carter Beard and some of the other early players in the Boy Scouts of America-
Really really interesting dynamic between those three.
And read the book and join us on Sunday, February 10th,
between 9 and 10 Eastern Standard Time
at scoutscircleorg for that live broadcast.
So coming up in this podcast, in Scout Master Ship in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk about reading Scout requirements
and then we have a couple of emails to answer in our email section
And that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout Master Ship in seven minutes
Or less.
So there's this guy. he goes out, he buys this new electronic gizmo
and he brings it home and he tries to get it to work
and it just won't work
And he spent a fair amount of money on it and he's getting a little chuffed.
So he finds the 800 number of the company,
he gets a representative on the phone
and he gives them a hard time because this gizmo just won't work
And they say, well, let's go through the troubleshooting list here
and he says, oh, it just doesn't work
and I need to figure out how to make it work.
And so the first step in the troubleshooting list
is: did you put the batteries in it?
And then there's a little silence on the other end of the phone
and the guy says: well, I think I know why it doesn't work. now
We've all had one of those experiences
where we got something and we were pretty sure
we absolutely knew how it would work.
so we just took it right out of the package
and started pressing buttons,
but found out that we actually didn't know.
So what did we do?
We read the manual. right,
We went and looked at the manual,
figured it out- usually something very simple,
just something we misunderstood.
and so we read the manual
and we figured out exactly how to make it work.
And I say that because sometimes,
when we're dealing with requirements
for merit badges or for ranks,
the way that we think that those requirements are fulfilled
does not really job with what's actually written
in the Boy Scout handbook.
Now let me preface this by saying
I don't sign off many requirements.
Requirements for ranks up to first class
are almost exclusively signed off by our older scouts.
I do sign the requirements
if I'm functioning as a merit badge counselor,
but not so much in my role as a scout master.
I need to train our older scouts
how to sign off requirements,
and when I do this,
I tell them to look for the verbs and modifiers
written in the requirements
and pay attention to them.
I tell them to read the requirement carefully,
no matter how many times they think they've signed it off,
and make sure that they're actually doing what it says,
rather than just glossing it over
or just going on what they think they understand
and getting the wrong idea.
If you're signing off requirements for ranks or merit badges,
this is a pretty crucial thing.
It's so simple that we miss it.
I've been counseling camping merit badge now for,
oh gosh, 20 years or so,
and I have learned to make myself go back
and read the requirements,
because to get them right
means understanding exactly what they say.
So here's some examples
of what I mean by actually reading these requirements:
The requirement for the scout badge,
the joining badge,
requirement number seven says:
understand and agree to live by the scout oath or promise
the scout law, the motto and the slogan
and the outdoor code.
Understand and agree-
two very important words here.
That does not mean repeat from memory.
In some ways, this is a higher standard
than just memorizing it.
I mean, what does it mean to be thrifty?
What does it mean to be reverent?
What does the outdoor code mean?
How are you going to live by it?
So this is not just memorizing these things,
but understanding them
and agreeing to live by them.
Now I will bet that some of you, listening
when you get to this requirement,
expect scouts to have these things memorized.
But that's not the important part of the requirement.
If you're joining scouts,
you need to understand these things
and you need to agree to live by them.
You don't have to have them memorized at that point,
because that will come later on.
I think it's in the tenderfoot requirements
where it says: repeat from memory.
Here's another typical word that you find in requirements.
Let's look at tenderfoot number 12B.
It says: show first aid for the following,
and then it lists a number of first aid scenarios.
Now, show does not mean talk about.
it does not mean write down,
It means show.
So, to complete this requirement,
a scout's going to use his hands and a first aid kit
and he's going to show what needs to happen
in the cases listed in that requirement.
Another good word to look for is demonstrate.
In second class 1A.
it asks a scout to demonstrate how a compass works
and how to orient a map
and then to explain what map symbols mean.
Demonstrate doesn't mean tell.
It means actively showing the skill,
Showing how it's accomplished,
using the actual tools required to accomplishment.
Explain indicates that a scout
should not only know the information
but is also needs to know what it means.
Those are other important verbs
and modifiers to look for.
First class number 6 says identify
or show evidence of at least 10 kinds
of native plants found in your community.
Identify means being able to recognize
or distinguish something,
and that's modified by show evidence of
indicating to me that the actual object
being identified may or may not be present.
It may not be the plant itself,
It may be a picture of it.
The modifier native is important too.
What does that mean
And how does it modify the type of plant
used to fulfill the requirement?
Requirement 3 begins with:
make a written plan for an overnight track
and show how to get to your camping spot
using a topographical map or compass etc.
Make a written plan
is not telling or demonstrating,
It's writing.
You don't see all that many requirements
that require book work or writing.
I mean thank goodness right.
But some of them are very specific
about producing a written plan.
When we read scout requirements
and take them at face value,
we'll better serve the intention
embedded in the scout requirement
and we'll be less likely to water them down
or to add to them.
Now we posted about this on the blog
a week or two ago
and it's had some great comments on it.
One came from Walter Underwood.
He said one other thing:
if you read carefully, the requirements are written
to allow for disabilities.
It doesn't say: write a plan,
Just make a written plan.
Maybe you need to dictate that plan to somebody,
And that's an excellent point.
Yes, there are alternative requirements
for scouts who are differently able,
but if you look at the requirements,
they will be able to do a lot of them
if you just read them carefully.
Now I did have one comment that I disagreed with,
and that was well. when you're checking
scouts off on requirements
or when scouts are being checked off on requirements,
other scouts shouldn't be able to listen in on that,
because then they'll just pair it what they heard
And you know what.
I don't agree with that
because I really don't care how a scout learns,
so long as he gets it,
And I'll bet he learned it pretty well
if he sees or hears the right skill
or information repeated a bunch of times,
watching other scouts repeat that same skill
or giving the same answer.
Years ago I was a counselor
for rifle-shooting merit badge at our summer camp
and counseled 20 to 30 scouts every week
And we had what I called a test on Friday
to certify some of the requirements for the badge.
When you're dealing with 30 guys every week,
you have to be creative in some of the evaluations.
The last thing I wanted to do
was give them a worksheet or something like that
and have them fill it out and then have me grade it
and then hand it back to them
and then have them hand it back to me.
And you know that's schoolwork.
We don't do schoolwork in scouts.
So this is the way that I used to handle these groups.
When Friday rolled around,
they would come down to the rifle range.
Each of them would have a piece of paper
and something to write with
and I would start asking them questions
or showing them something
that they had to name
and write their answer on a piece of paper,
And I guess there was maybe 20 questions
or 20 things that I would show them
and they would write them down on the paper
and when we were finished doing that,
they would exchange that paper with another scout.
Let's say, number one was the three rules
for safe firearms handling,
And we would go over that
point by point
and make sure that everybody had it right.
if they didn't have it right,
Well, you know, circle the number there
and we'll move on.
Now, once we went through all the questions,
the papers were given back to the original owners
and anyone who had answered them
all correctly was done.
I asked for their paper.
I recorded the fact that they knew
what they were talking about
and they had finished that part of the merit page.
Scouts who had a wrong answer
stayed right there
and I talked to each one individually,
within the earshot
of everybody else,
and I would ask them to give me the right answers
Now. they had just heard the right answer.
They had just heard the right answer
because we had just gone over them
with the whole group.
If they couldn't remember the right answer,
I pointed them to a copy of the merit page book
and asked them to look up the right answer
and then I moved on to the next scout.
Pretty soon the whole group had figured out,
they could talk to each other
and help each other get all the answers right.
Needless to say, the scouts
who hadn't bothered to know anything,
who hadn't- quote unquote- studied
for the test,
had heard the correct answers
and repeated several times by now
and they had to sit down with me
individually and they had to give me the correct answer
and I'm confident
that when they all left the rifle range
they knew their stuff and we had
actually a pretty good time getting there.
It doesn't matter to me how they learn things.
if they hear it repeated all the time, it's fine.
I understand that school wants to build
study habits and things like that
and you know that's all good.
but we're not school.
We don't use school methods of instructing
or testing. We use scouting methods.
How do scouts learn?
Any way they can, and I can't think of
any wrong way
to learn the right things.
I,
I.
I. had an email this week from
Brad in New Hampshire.
He says our troop is getting ready
to realign patrols. I've read the patrol
method in practice on your website.
If boys choose their own patrols,
what happens
to several scouts in our troop
who are not necessarily liked
by all the scouts? Do they wind up without
a patrol? If they choose
a patrol, can the patrol
of scouts refuse them?
Well, Brad, thanks for getting in touch
and thanks for this question.
Just to catch everybody up, we talk
about scouts choosing their own patrols,
The patrol leaders council sitting down,
figuring things out, letting them
sort it out.
There is always the kind of danger
of that
scenario that we've seen again and again
of like picking teams
or something and
the athletic guy is kind of
the last guy picked
and nobody wants to create
anything like that. If your troop doesn't
already have a kind of accepting, friendly
culture, you need to work
on creating that a little bit. You may
ask for a few minutes of time
before the scouts are going to do all this
and talk to the whole troop
and ask a scout to read
from the handbook the definition
of what it says in the scout law
when we pledge ourselves to be friendly.
It says: a scout is friendly,
a scout's a friend to all,
he's a brother to all scouts.
he offers his friendship to people of all races,
religions and nations
and respects them, even if their beliefs
and customs are different from his own.
And then start asking the boys
some questions about this.
What does being friendly mean?
How do you treat people that you don't
really like? What
things do people do that makes you
dislike them?
What does it feel like when other people
aren't friendly to you?
Why do you suppose being friendly is
a point of the scout law?
In what way does our troop
best demonstrate being friendly?
In what ways could we do a better job
of being friendly?
And then, you know, maybe tell a story about a time
you felt left out personally,
when nobody chose you for their
team, or something like that,
and encourage your scouts
to think about the choices
they're about to make. Tell them that
scouts is about
working with every other scout
and finding a way to be their friend,
even if you don't like them all that much.
What if everybody worked
very hard to do this? What if everybody
tried to find a way to be a friend
to everyone they came in contact with?
What would our world look like then?
Maybe use this thought:
Imagine we're out camping and a fellow
scout is injured. Well, what would you do?
That's right. You'd come to his aid and help him.
What if he's someone you don't particularly like,
or someone who doesn't particularly
like you? You know what I mean.
We all work hard to get along, but sometimes
we fall short. If you were hurt,
you'd be looking for help and you'd accept
help from just about anyone, wouldn't you?
If you saw somebody who was hurt,
you'd offer them help, right.
You wouldn't walk away from them just because
they acted or differently
or dressed differently or looked differently
than you did. right. In the same way,
you'd freely offer your help to anyone
injured physically. like that,
it's just as important
to freely offer your friendship.
Sometimes it's hard to do because
other people can be difficult to like.
You can be difficult to like,
I can be difficult to like.
It's true of everybody sometimes.
One of the things that marks a good
scout is being friendly,
kind, helpful and loyal
to others. We ought to make sure
that it starts here. whenever
we're together with our fellow scouts,
Look around this room.
Every single scout in this room
is your friend. They'll be there for you
and you'll be there for them.
You don't have to like everything about them
and they don't have to like everything about you,
because you're scouts and that's really
all that matters. Now I've been around long
enough to understand that you can
talk all this stuff and you can
share this with scouts and it may get through
and it may not. You may have to talk
and counsel with individual scouts.
You may need to work with your older scouts
thinking about these things.
This sort of thing is really kind of
heavy lifting for a scout master.
It can take a while to create an atmosphere
of acceptance, but once you do it,
it tends to stay around for a long time.
So, Brad, I hope that helps and I
appreciate you sending in your question.
You can certainly send in a question
and get in touch with us. We
really appreciate it when you do, and
you'll learn how to do that in just a moment.
Thank you
Well, thank you so much for listening
to this edition of the scout master podcast.
Now here's how you can stay in touch.
Read the scoutmaster blog at
scoutmastercgcom and while
you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can subscribe to the scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes and when you do,
please leave a comment or review or
a rating. You can also access
the podcast on your mobile device through
Stitcher Smart Radio. Get details
about how to make that happen at
wwwstitchercom.
You can experience the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom through the
vast panorama of
social media outlets.
Follow us at scoutmaster blog on Facebook,
Tweet scoutmastercg on
Twitter and, for admittance to the
exclusive scoutmastercg circle, search
for scoutmastercg
on Google Plus. Please email
me, Clark Green, with your comments, questions
and interesting ideas
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
The scoutmaster blog and the
scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by
the Boy Scouts of America. It's just me
talking into a microphone, trying to lend
a hand to scout leaders and perhaps
have a little bit of fun along the way.
And before we leave you, here is our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Pal. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why, thank you, Sir?
Until next time.
Thank you.